[Musique]
c'est un petit village niché entre l'eau
et la terre sur les berges du Richelieu
un jet de pierre du lac Champlain et de
la frontière américaine mais noyant
c'est aussi des champs de maïs à perte
de vue
sans surprise les plus chères
constituent donc au village le clou de
la fête l'occasion pour les résidents de
Noyant de se détendre de se retrouver
après une pandémie synonyme de
distanciation de division dans le
village les pancartes électorales ont
fait leur apparition mais la campagne ne
passionne pas ici tout au plus
offrent-elles l'occasion d'accorder une
note au gouvernement sortant et à sa
gestion des crises sanitaire il y a
quand même bien moi je donnerai envie
moi je suis satisfait de ce qui a été
fait puis je trouve que le gouvernement
bien agi au moment ce qu'il fallait
réagissent oui je vais continuer il faut
se protéger de là à imposer le port du
masque moi ça j'en veux pas quand même
content de venir chercher je pense que
ils ont fait le maximum pour le protéger
le monde
[Musique]
des opinions sans doute pas très
éloignées de ce qu'il dit ailleurs au
Québec
car noyant est-ce que l'on pourrait
appeler un village baromètre depuis
trois scrutins les électeurs de Noyant
votent au gré du vent chaque fois pour
le parti appelé à former le prochain
gouvernement autre particularité locale
les gens ici ont voté en faveur de la
Coalition avenir Québec lors de la
dernière élection avant de se retrouver
avec une députée conservatrice après le
changement d'allégeance de clarçons
[Musique]
on cultive la terre de père en fils une
tradition qui fait la fierté de real
l'agriculteur est aussi le maire de
Noyant et le développement des régions
est au cœur de ses préoccupations
fait partie du Québec et regarder
combien il y a de ruralité sur le
territoire du Québec ça représente
probablement
80% du Québec
il faut maintenir
selon lui la difficulté de trouver des
travailleurs constituent l'un des
principaux obstacles au développement ce
que le dossier la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre c'est très très préoccupant
la ferme de real Ryan se trouve à 2 km
de la frontière américaine une frontière
que l'on devrait ouvrir davantage selon
lui pour pas dire aux problèmes de main
d'oeuvre c'est sûr qu'on en a besoin ça
va aider à combler le manque de
c'est bon d'avoir des gens de chez nous
mais c'est pas évident d'avoir des gens
de chez nous
la fromagerie Fredd Kaiser est
probablement le plus gros employeur du
village on vit donc ici le problème de
façon encore plus aiguë les 18 employés
à temps plein ne suffisent clairement
pas à l'attache mais incapable de
recruter davantage le patron a du
rabattre sur l'automatisation
comme ce robot programmé pour laver les
fromages dans ce contexte
fritzgere très mal les propos de
François Legault sur l'immigration les
freinés parce qu'ils parlent pas la
langue
je trouve ça ridicule pour ce Québécois
d'origine suisse cela ne fait aucun
doute les immigrants sont une richesse
pour le Québec pas une menace qu'il
parle de français ou non
sur la rive du Richelieu face au célèbre
pont tournant se dresse un géant
solitaire
[Musique]
le plus gros arbre du Québec selon les
gens du coin qui en sont très fiers
d'auteur c'est 28 pieds de circonférence
ça prend cinq grandes personnes des
grandes politiques pour faire le tour
une attraction touristique située sur le
terrain de Paul Picard mais l'homme
d'affaires n'en profite plus son auberge
est fermée depuis quelques années et à
vendre c'est un problème de main
d'oeuvre on avait un noyau de 5 à 6
personnes
ne cache pas son insatisfaction au sujet
du gouvernement sortant pour
réellement aider les gens ils sont
proches du zéro mais Paul Picard se
pense minoritaire à Noyant avec ce que
j'entends partout là les gens barboter
claques encore l'habitude des gens de la
place c'est de voter pour celui qui va
au pouvoir pour être capable d'avoir des
choses des autres
c'est donc potentiellement là le secret
des électeurs de noyens si ce village
baromètre est représentatif de
l'ensemble du Québec quant aux
intentions de vote c'est peut-être tout
simplement un reflet du pragmatisme de
ses habitants